on March 15 2012 film courage sat down
with filmmaker Morgan Spurlock at a
press roundtable interview regarding his
movie comic-con episode for a fans hope
along with one of the doc stars Holly
Conrad this audio is an excerpt of that
interview to find out more about this
amazing look at comic-con and the fans
at a ten please visit comic-con movie
com hero powers count on I do have this
meant that's mustache so I happy I have
the power of mustache I get mustache
power whenever I need it and luckily I
had I had the the power of about one
hundred and forty nine other people we
make a good movie I mean we had the
biggest crew I've ever worked with in my
life and making a movie it was massive a
huge camera Department audio department
at any given time there were in as many
as 25 to 27 cameras shooting at once to
capture the whole of comic-con and in
all its glory but it was was a massive
undertaking I had great people and
Gregory cast you know sir thank God we
had amazing stories like Holly and
interchange darling and say young and
skip and Eric so what's good and yet God
on your side stay away that's right and
I had the god of comic-con it was like
who is been watching over us yeah hey
Morgan and I wrote the book progressive
Hollywood yes film history of the United
States together in yeah yeah you bought
a copy for the categories right to
happen again on your work is often had
an anti-corporate edge can you discuss
the commercialization del comic-con and
the issue of the purists versus the
other non comic books Pacific
participants yeah I think that um you
know people love to say that it's not
what it used to be no comic-con's not
what you see with comic book vendors and
my very first Comic Con that I ever went
to and I was probably was anyone san
diego comic-con but a comic book
convention when i was probably 10 11 12
years old in charleston west virginia
where I grew up it was at like the
ballroom at a hotel there and they were
common
vendors there people are selling comic
books and there were guys selling all
the toys and tie-ins from those comic
books already that existed in lunch
boxes because out back when lunch boxes
were still a big deal and then there
were people doing autographs and like
the guy who played c-3po was there
signing autographs and so it's all ready
then it was bigger than just somebody
selling you a comic book and I think
that what's happenin sis just continued
to blossom as these things have become
infinitely more popular as it comes down
to reading comics I read more comics now
that i read as a kid I ain't buying more
comments now than I ever did as a kid I
don't I don't buy a physical paper
comics you know I download everything
straight to my ipad now which I think
that ease-of-use has made consumption of
comics even easier to a greater audience
so I don't buy into the idea that it's
destroying or changing complic industry
I think maybe people aren't buying old
paper comics anymore but I think that
this commercialization has only helped
the industry because it has made it so
immensely popular like to give good luck
turning on the TV in July and not even
seeing a story in Omaha Nebraska about
comic-con that's how popular this has
become and it's and it literally is this
this triumph of geek culture in that
everybody's a geek now and everybody can
proudly say it and you can go outside
and you can wear your decoder rings and
you can put on your Spock ears and you
can wear your you can wear your Hobbit
feet to work and you know and be like
listen this is who I am and people are
like all yeah he's a geek kind of cool
though the obsession is now not seen as
being a negative would you say you have
more going on right now than we did in
2004 it seems like oh yeah you know it's
it's working full Sun suddenly after
Super Size Me everybody return my phone
call
if it becomes it becomes a very
different world when people call you
back and when people actually you know
you don't want to work with you and you
know and with this film to you know add
to fortunate you know the luck to work
with someone like Stanley with Joss with
Thomas toll with Harry Knowles you know
I mean it's it's a dream come true this
movie I got apart from everyone being
huge fans of just comics in general yeah
what did you kind of how did you decide
to kind of narrow down the field down
what were you sort of looking for as a
thematic through line and all the people
that you were profile I think the key
for us from the beginning you know when
when I got the idea knows myself and my
producing partner Jeremy Cilic you know
we were at comic-con making the simpsons
20 anniversary special for Fox when we
kind of said let's make a movie about
this you know I meant Stan Stan was one
and said we should make a documentary
like yes we should in luckily that night
that night Jeremy and are like what
what's the movie about who would be in
it what would we do and we prefer for me
and for he and I both we realized that
the telus sort of comment on us to tell
the story of fans to tell the store
because Comic Con wouldn't exist if it
wasn't for fans video game culture
wouldn't exist it wasn't for fans the
movies that are so big and popular
wouldn't exist if it wasn't for them and
so we wanted to root it in fan culture
the people who literally are the driving
force of comic-con and the people who
are the passion and so we started
thinking about well who are those people
what do they do and so whether you're a
comic book vendor who's been doing it
for the last 30 years or you're somebody
who is making a costume to go compete in
the contest or you're taking your
portfolio to like lay in your ego and
the tables in front of you know the
people of Marvel DC or dark force you
know we wanted to make sure we rooted in
those stories that a lot of people maybe
wouldn't get to see or understand or
have access to the collector it's me
like Anthony holder on who literally
drove six hours just to go get his
Galactus figure the only of the only
place the only place that you can buy it
at comic-con you know I mean that type
of passion is is incredible so for us
that was we really wanted to root it in
them first with the offshoot being you
know the people that you know kind of
you you expect to see at a comic con
like a Kevin Smith or a Seth Green or
Seth Rogen or something like that with
the characters he re with the
characters he followed from the
beginning before you hit the con how did
you find what was it written policies
for we had a we had a massive casting
call like we sit it out through
shops we had like signs or putting comic
book shops we had we had mailings that
went out through other con san diego
comic-con helped us with something with
some aliens with from them an equal news
you know Harry they say put it out on
their website we were looking for people
for the film and we got probably two
thousand submissions from around the
world people who sent his sin as first
they said his paper submissions then we
went through all those whittled them
down and then say way back to them said
could you send us videos those people
send us videos and from those we
whittled them down holly was one of the
first videos we got she was probably the
first person that we said yes this is a
story we want to tell because of just
the imagery of her and her garage with
her friends making this costume telling
her story how this is all she's ever
wanted to do you know that to her like
the video game cultures of like mass
effect that you know this is like the
Star Wars of her generation like these
are where her stories come from you know
me there's so much that I related to
with her story and actually I showed it
everyone you know to to stand and Josh
and Thomas and Harry and they were all
like she's perfect is exactly what she
is what this movie is about and and then
she literally became kind of the model
of like who else who else should be the
people that we want to fall in this
movie and there are people who I think
shared the passion that Holly had and
kind of have this vision of that you
know the comic-con is a very special
place where things out of the ordinary
can happen you where you can get a
career you know you could buy the toy
that you want if that's the reason you
want to go to but there's other real
fulfilling things that can happen there
ollie how is life changed for you since
the filming of the whole project and now
you know you're blowing up here on a 22
pitch for your audition oh yeah yeah how
does this feel I no obvious the effect
hasn't hit yet because sometimes not
outfit what is that I'm not even
thinking about that that's too intense
for me but um no I mean after after all
of that happened like my life changed
absolutely completely like you know I
mean I ended up leaving you know
Highland in San Bernardino move to LA
you know I ended up you know working for
bio where I did a bunch of costumes for
them for comic-con i was there official
fem shep for a couple like cons as well
and i did that and we did a live action
trailer for them and I actually recently
did a project with say and James they
did they were doing producing an art
directing I did
design so I actually got to make
creatures and monsters for a short that
we all worked on too so it's kind of
been like meeting people doing cool
things and like spiraling out of control
and an awesome yes do you actually do
costumes for people that I have costume
from comic-con it's falling apart nah I
you know honestly it's been I've been so
busy working on stuff that I actually
haven't even been able to take all the
jobs i've been offered the choice yeah i
think well it's been crazy because I've
also been making my own suits and doing
the suits for bio or so it's just been I
mean it's it's it's great but yeah no
yeah no yeah all right all right Erin
tlemen digging a nice girl actually went
to comic-con last year and compress and
just I was actually I was kind of
focusing on the whole love aspect and
the whole female aspect it's really
great Holly that you were program the
story on you in this movie because I
think there's a lot of girls who are
going to comic-con now I don't you know
I think it's really great oh so Morgan
how important was it for you to bring in
a female and like a love story in this
movie because I think it was a really
great aspect okay I couldn't just gone
and or a you know comic book whatever I
think like this there's so many
misconceptions people have with comic
con impart of things that I wanted to do
is shatter a lot of those ideas of
stereotypes with the movie i think the
film shows there are really cool smart
empowered enlightening girls to go to
comic-con that are shaping changes visit
there are there are there are there is
like hot nerd love going on oh god I
know it I work and I wanted to show
people that you know that there is
there's this other side I know but from
this from these women who are impacting
the business and also from this idea
that you can find a club like you can
both come together and bond over whether
it's Twilight or your hunger games
fetishes or whatever it may be there's
something for all of you and what can
that's what I want think I love that is
setting the phones i love guillermo del
toro taught me about it where he
compares comic-con to a Russian doll
they says he was within comic-con there
are so many other comic-con right that
you know I sure the movie to people feel
like I didn't even know that was there I
didn't have no idea idea this exists and
you know that there is something for
everyone no matter who you are what your
passion that there's something for you a
comic com what somebody that I think at
the end of the movie we even said
something about like how many girls
there was a panel what happened during
the filming that was unexpected to that
surprised to be a big storyline well
there just before we even started doing
that like the the idea of comic-con as
geek job fair like I thought was one of
those things that until we really
started talking about it I didn't have
an idea of how large a portion of the
column that could actually even be of
people who were going there and there's
other parts of that that we didn't even
show like there's people who went there
you know hard from like skipping Eric
who are going there show their
portfolios like their stories are great
nurs there's thousands of guys are going
there and girls they're doing just that
showing their portfolios to you know
Marvel DC Dark Horse you name it the
people who enter into the masquerade
whoo-hoo you hopefully have to be
selected like their snouts people is
submitted of which they pick I don't
know what a 50mm something like
something really small as a lot we're
just held a lot you know to run through
over the for our show which is very long
but at same time the day that was
whittled down so much that people
actually get to come and compete for the
chance to kind of say this is how good
my costumes and my designs are and when
you win it becomes a big deal that you
are recognized as being one of the best
you know up and cummers in the business
and then you have people who are there
doing toy design who are there like
shopping toy models and toy molds and
and
and an artists like you know fine
artists who are there you know creating
artwork to sell or set up at galleries I
mean there's there's so many pieces to
this puzzle of I'm going to go there and
show my wares and find my place in this
business there for me I think that was
probably the most surprising thing
because I concluded that that was like
such a big part of that of that place
it's not just people going to be up late
video games and it's an all age and
watch the movie trailers yeah your
favorite comic books your favorite
superheroes and your favorite superhero
movies when I was a kid growing up I
loved Plastic Man that project
management call me was the comic book
that I read all the time comic Plastic
Man was the was the movie as I was
growing up late if I could make a
superhero movie I would want to make
plastic man like I love to Plastic Man
so much and my superhero movies that I
love what I loved for like two year ago
two years ago I thought Thor was
fantastic I am beyond excited for the
Avengers I came and tell you I think
Marvel has done such a smart job of
interweaving all of their universes
together in in all of their storylines
it's genius you know I love the dark
knight reboot I think that whole thing
was so smart and so well done by
Christopher Nolan and even you know back
of the day I remember when as a kid when
I was probably 12 years old no it would
have been with your Center was a 78 the
first Superman came out I remember I
went to the movie theater see the very
first kiss for Superman and I thought it
was like the most magical thing to see
in a movie theater and I get so I just
got chills thinking about like I said
there I was there with my one thing that
we do is that as a family was weird to
see movies all the time and I remember
being in the movie theater with my
parents watching this film and it was
just such this magical thing that was
happening watching the first Superman
and you watch it today and you're like
wow that movie looks terrible
at the time it was a clash the titans of
the same way i love 5 titans which came
out and i love the array / touring with
you know I've started came out it wasn't
boys named Tom Jones I wasn't Tom Jones
fam Jam Jones the same joke fire go
clash go like I love that movie that's
in fact was bad but uh but the you watch
this movie now maybe not so much public
but at the time it was so special Morgan
sincerely importance of culture
throughout memory but in the future like
what would you advise prospering or
potential filmmakers for special arguing
documentaries I mean I tell any trouble
eggers gonna make it doc I say you
better be you better make sure it's
something you a story you love that's
the biggest thing you're gonna make a
documentary it better be a store you
love and you gotta think about that
because you got to love it on day 794 as
much as you do on day one because most
docs take a long time like this film we
started we basically got the idea in
2009 you see a comic con 2009 now here
we are coming up on three almost three
years from that day and it's just now
getting ready come out into theaters so
it was a long long process getting the
money getting approval from comic-con
you know getting the crew together
shooting it editing it going to
festivals now is coming out so it's you
need to really be passionate about that
story and need to be something that you
are just you want to share you know if
they do become your children in a lot of
ways like that's I person make the
Lakers talk to of it it is because you
love them all you look a little
differently but you still love them all
you know hand but you know for me it's
it's yeah it's it's all about your
passion you kind of touched earlier on
skip and eric and i kinda wanna come
back to that real quick just it was such
to the two guys going for the same thing
that we saw kind of a triumph and a
little bit of a tragedy but would skip
p1 i just got to come back and get
better and we know like for me with
erica you just don't see that many
african-american illustrators a comic
book people in job for him to get picked
up a whole audience so wish
so you know we found ourselves crying
for two different reasons we crying for
Eric but we are crying for skin as well
because you know eric is kind of a drop
in the bucket you know because you have
so many people that job done don't hit
lightning the first time around so my
question is have you checked in with
these two guys in primary military eric
is still in the air force he's now
stationed in Germany he has yet to see
the film and I just called him yeah we
just told him to say here's the phone's
going to the premiere of the film's
gonna be April fourth in Los Angeles we
really want you to come and he's like I
have to be there so now he's trying to
figure out what the airport's how he can
be here since then you know he's he's
done I mean how many covers for
archenemy three or four now he's doing I
think he's now doing some stuff for
marble like the guy the guy is so she's
so talented you know and it's his work
is so clean and so impressive and skip
who has the passion but hasn't developed
kind of a lot of the skill set you know
to be that level of ave of an have a
designer and as an artist so he's
continuing to work on his own stuff he's
working on his own graphic novel right
now continue together portfolio but my
prediction is that this movie that skip
will still make I think skip will make
its own I think he will get to maybe
will self publish his own grab available
I think that'll happen what system how
would you like to have I would love to
be able to speak any language in the
universe yes yeah that would be my
superpower thank you okay cool you guys
thank you so much